well what are we fixing today today is a
day we work on the tractor it's been
freaking years because I've been
just you know sometimes you get
frustrated with things and you don't
find a way out until you decide you need
a way out now this trailer
here I need out by the end of the uh
September or so I need that and the
tractor is in front of it and the
tractor
tire
here is
flat so I need to fix this so I can move
this and get that we're also going to
have to fix some bumper hitch stuff so
more to come today we're going to work
on the
tire
and the tire
is O look at
that look at that
Mama Is it
alive
no not alive okay that's
good it might be some murder hornet in
here somewhere I don't know but this is
a where's the size yeah size is right
there 13.6 by 28 tire and a rim that
goes all the way around I have to pop it
off because you look around here there's
some rot but if you
look where is it
here there's a hole and this hole has
rubbed the tube so I need
to push this back
get the tube out replace it and then
over the top of this wherever it's sharp
I need to do something to make sure it's
not sharp it doesn't actually have to be
sealed it just has to be not
sharp so that's what we're going to work
on today I have tried removing the
bolts and then I was thinking like okay
I remove the bolts and then I take it
off the rim but I'm like what in the
hell I don't
know you see people online beating on
these with sledgehammers as hard as I
can but
uh I found something online it's an
Amazon product so we'll see if it works
it's supposed to be able to take these
off the
rim and I don't have to do a lot of
taking off the rim kind of thing I just
have to get
it somewhat off the
rim just the front part really so I can
reach in here so
it is currently jacked up or at least on
jack stands and a block of wood under
there so I got to raise it up some more
cuz it has sunk into the ground so we're
going to raise it up get this wheel so
it
spins use the magic tool to try to pop
this out and if we get past that then
we're going to start fixing it and
putting it back together
so let's try that
all right this is the thing I bought and
yes I bought it from the warehouse cuz
that's where I buy almost
everything I need to open it up and see
what size wrench I need for this
all
right these are the directions they have
a big caution on it I wonder what it
says this is the
thing all I have is a silver socket that
size and
have a uh
impact socket I'm going to be putting an
impact on it so we'll see how that goes
now we got to Jack this
up I jacked it up from here before this
is the bucket
this up again
fire Jack from
neighbor I'm guess say 4,000 lb this is
half of it
off the
ground up
here I'll find some other jack stands
for that see the right place
[Music]
okay Jack is loose tire is
loose
okay so the next step is up here I have
to remove the Val stem from the
tube
because yeah there's a hole in the in
tube but it is a slow leak and you can't
have any back pressure on you when
you're doing this
[Music]
let's start like right
here so I
need
this there's a oldie but a probably not
so
goodie let's make sure this is in all
the
way now
even there that's out of the way get
this here is I'm going to pound this in
I
believe look good
okay there are ways tighten up on this
one should pull it in further
see the
stop then you pull on this
[Music]
for
this I have good old
trusty yep and it's a silver socker on
a on a uh impact but sorry
[Music]
all right we're going to move it
now ah
that's
exciting thank you
Vore I know there was a pin in there I
know what the pin
is
so on the first
use I have the first failure
it either sheared that pin or it just
fell out oh it just fell out here it
is p just fell
out oh
Lovely Isn't She Lovely
so what happened
was this pin here fell out not that it
wasn't
fixable but why should it be happening e
[Music]
oh
and there it is it's off
[Music]
wo w
oh
[Music]
set the
ground so it's off
got to go higher now
[Music]
okay and I looked as I was coming out I
saw the
hole all these chunks of were in
there before here's the
whole and it was this is right where
that hole was and the other
stuff so this kind of blistered out and
just
blue now how do I clean this
up because there is Ain ton of in
there I I'm going to have to pop the
other
loose I don't see a way around
it so I
guess let's go
[Music]
w
oh well that was easier than the other
side
e one grab
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
w
oh
[Music]
w
okay
off look how much was inside there
all parts of the rim that's all got to
be cleaned
out this has got three holes in
it that's take the rest of this off and
who knows I might find some
more wire brush this
up try to treat
it paint
it might be another hole under
there I'm going to do all that
offline and we show you what we're going
to do about these CU right here is where
it bolts through and two broke
so as you can tell here I've given it
the old Earl shy
Rehabilitation I got three
holes I got a little hole there I don't
know if you can see
it right
there
so I cleaned it as best as I could wash
it with some solvent
painted it with a
brown uh rust Rusty primer painted it
with a white primer and painted with
orange now it's painted with orange and
it's all chers you know it's got to be
good that's all it
needs I have
then my house and
got Gorilla Tape weather patch
this stuff is sticky and why I'm using
this is not the seal Air at all it's
just to keep water from getting back and
rusting this out some more as much as
possible this stuff is sticky
sticky right's a
chunk let's use this one here
[Applause]
over this
hole okay so we got
this we got this I have to try to hold
that down
somehow so I think I'm just going to go
find some duck tape tape the
edges once the tube's in here this
certainly isn't going to
move I just when I put the tube in the
tire in and all that I got to keep this
down where it belongs
well I out a battery in the
phone
so don't know where you left
off but what I did was I put down some
gorilla seal tape to make sure that the
holes don't leak water back up laay down
a piece of sheet
aluminum and tape that down to make sure
that the tube doesn't buol through and
now I have to create a new
pole for the valve stem to come
out now we're going to get Russell on
one side
side of the tire
[Music]
ah well it's on but my foot's
stuck
okay on
now the
tube has to go
on going try to stuff this in
there best I
can not getting it
pinched
W looks like I was able to stretch it
around there
now
maybe add little
air keep make sure it doesn't pinch make
sure it's laying
correctly okay now it's got a little bit
of a shape
all
right
hey it's onun
wow that is so much not not
fun all right a check locking a
check this is kind of a dangerous Air
truck it's got a lock on
it you have to watch it
[Music]
check if it's on in the
back it is
I going he right here seeping
out well
I think that's
it well that's going to be the end of
the day it's getting late
anyway uh so this has 7 and 12 lbs of
air in it come back in a couple days and
check it make sure it's okay uh you know
if not then I got to take it all apart
again fix the tube uh I found in the
other side it's still full of calcium
chloride so I can't really check that
one to compare it so that's happening
anyway thanks for watching give me a
like if you think you learned something
if you have any questions because I
couldn't film it all really well uh let
me
know uh I'll tell you how I wrestled
this tire on you kind of watched some of
it but it was
problem
um take a look at what the patches look
like
the one on the
old behind there is the other one
so that Gorilla Tape is sticking out
there and I'm thinking about I might put
some epoxy on the top just to fill it in
and protect it a little more but that's
it for
today uh next time we'll see what we can
do about going for a tractor ride soon
hey since it's should be working
good uh until next time always make sure
you know what tube you put in your tire
bye
[Music]